thank you
we are handing down our judgments in
these appeals this morning I shall read
a summary which does not form part of
the judgment
the appellants in these cases are 10
individual Asylum Seekers and one
charity Asylum Aid
the individual appellants are from Syria
Iraq Iran Vietnam Sudan and Albania
they arrived in the United Kingdom
irregularly by crossing the English
Channel from France in small boats
in the cases of each of the appellants
the government made a decision in late
May or early June 2022 not to consider
their Asylum claims but to remove them
to Rwanda where their claims would be
decided under the Rwandan Asylum system
those decisions were made in accordance
with Arrangements between the two
governments announced on the 14th of
April 2022
and contained in a memorandum of
understanding and a number of diplomatic
notes for Bal
they comprised the Rwanda agreement
on the basis of the assurances from the
Rwandan government contained in the
terms of the Rwanda agreement its terms
more broadly monitoring Arrangements in
place and other inquiries carried out by
the United Kingdom government
Rwanda was treated as a safe Third
Country under the relevant provisions of
the immigration rules this is the Rwanda
policy
the appellants and other claimants
brought proceedings in the high court
challenging both the lawfulness of the
Rwanda policy generally referred to as
the generic Challenge and the
government's decisions specifically to
remove each of them to Rwanda
removals did not go ahead pending the
outcome of these proceedings
the central issue before the high court
and before us was whether the Asylum
system in Rwanda was capable of
delivering reliable outcomes
the appellance case is that there are
substantial grounds for believing that
there is a real risk that any person
sent to Rwanda will be removed to their
home country when in fact they have a
good claim for Asylum
sending them to Rwanda in those
circumstances would breach article 3 of
the European convention on human rights
in that sense the appellants submitted
that Rwanda is not a safe Third Country
the high court law Justice Lewis and Mr
Justice Swift heard those challenges in
September and October 2022
its decision was handed down on the 19th
of December 2022
in the case of the individual claimants
the decisions to remove them were
quashed on the basis of procedural
unfairness in their particular cases
but the court dismissed the generic
challenges to the Rwanda policy
the appeals to this court are against
the high Court's decision on the generic
challenges
the government has not appealed against
the quashing of the decisions in the
appellants individual cases and has not
yet made any fresh decisions in those or
other cases pending the outcome of the
Appeals
the appeals were argued before us over
four days between the 24th and the 27th
of April 2023
the grounds were numerous and included
other legal issues besides the question
whether Rwanda was a safe Third Country
in the sense we have described
the court had to consider a great deal
of detailed evidence as well as other
materials
the United Nations High Commissioner for
refugees was permitted to make
submissions as an interested party
and evidence filed on behalf of the
unhcr formed the foundation of much of
the appellant's case
by a majority this court allows the
appeal on the issue of whether Rwanda is
a safe Third Country
it unanimously dismisses the other
grounds
there is a subsidiary question about
whether there are substantial grounds
for believing that persons sent to
Rwanda will face a real risk of
treatment contrary to article 3 in
Rwanda itself
although we do not all take the same
view on that subsidiary question the
decision of the high court is
undisturbed on that point
I will now give a very brief summary of
the court of appeals reasons
to understand the detail it is necessary
to read the judgments which will be made
available in court and online as soon as
I have delivered this summary
the decision of the majority the master
of the roles Sir Jeffrey Voss and Lord
Justice Underhill the vice president of
the court of appealed Civil Division
is that the deficiencies in the Asylum
system in Rwanda are such that there are
substantial grounds for believing that
there is a real risk that persons sent
to Rwanda will be returned to their home
countries where they faced persecution
or other inhumane treatment when in fact
they have a good claim for Asylum
in that sense Rwanda is not a safe Third
Country
that conclusion is founded on the
evidence which was before the high court
that rwanda's system for deciding Asylum
claims was in the period up to the
conclusion of the Rwanda agreement
inadequate
the court is unanimous in accepting that
the assurances given by the Rwandan
government were made in good faith and
were intended to address any defects in
the Asylum process
however the majority believes that the
evidence does not establish that the
necessary changes have by then been
reliably affected
or would have been at the time of the
proposed removals
in consequence sending anyone to Rwanda
would constitute a breach of article 3
of the European convention on human
rights which Parliament has required the
government to comply with
in agreement with the high court I have
reached the opposite conclusion
I agree that the procedures put in place
under the Rwandan agreement and the
assurances given by the Rwandan
government are sufficient to ensure that
there is no real risk that Asylum
Seekers relocated under the Rwanda
policy will be wrongly returned to
countries where they face persecution or
other inhumane treatment
I have concluded that the chances of
failed Asylum Seekers being returned to
their countries of origin are in any
event low not least because Rwanda has
no agreements in place with any of the
countries in question
in addition extensive monitoring
Arrangements formal and informal of all
those sent to Rwanda and of their Asylum
claims once there provide powerful
protection
I take the view that the arrangements
put in place provide sufficient
safeguards in a context where both
governments will be determined to make
the agreement work and be seen to do so
as for the grounds on which the
appellants have been unsuccessful I can
summarize our reasoning as follows one
the effect of the refugee convention
article 31 of the refugee convention
does not in principle prevent the United
Kingdom from removing Asylum Seekers to
a safe Third Country
two retained EU law
EU law only permits Asylum Seekers to be
removed to a safe Third Country if they
have some connection to that country
none of the appellants has any
connection to Rwanda
however the court holds that the that
that requirement has ceased to be part
of United Kingdom law as a result of the
provisions of the immigration and Social
Security cooperation EU withdrawal act
2020 which is part of the legislation
dealing with the consequences of the
UK's withdrawal from the European Union
three designation is a safe Third
Country
schedule 3 to the Asylum and immigration
treatment of claimants act 2004 allows
the government as long as it obtains
parliamentary approval to designate
particular countries as safe
the government did not in these cases
make use of those procedures instead it
proceeded by giving guidance to
caseworkers for application in
individual decision
the court holds that it was not unlawful
for it to proceed in that way
four data protection
decisions to remove individuals to
Rwanda are not themselves invalidated by
any breaches of the data protection
legislation which it is alleged would or
might occur in the course or in
consequence of their removal
5. fairness of procedures
Asylum Aid submitted that the procedures
by which the government decided whether
to relocate individual Asylum Seekers to
Rwanda were inherently unfair in
particular because of the short
timetable applying to representations
seeking to resist removal
the court rejects that submission
but it holds that some aspects of the
high Court's reasoning cannot be
supported and that the government needs
to give guidance to caseworkers
emphasizing the importance of
flexibility in granting extensions to
the time limits where fairness requires
the result is that the high Court's
decision that Rwanda was a safe third
country is reversed and that unless and
until the deficiencies in its Asylum
processes are corrected removal of
Asylum Seekers to Rwanda will be
unlawful
finally I should make clear that our
decision implies no view whatever about
the political merits or otherwise of the
Rwanda policy those are entirely a
matter for the government on which the
court has nothing to say our concern is
only whether the policy complies with
the law as laid down by Parliament
a deliberately tight timetable has been
set for consequential orders and
directions partly so that any
application for permission to appeal can
be decided promptly
the court hopes and expects that it will
be able to deal with all consequential
matters on the papers
for the avoidance of Doubt our judgments
are published with immediate effect
albeit on a subject to editorial
Corrections basis in accordance uh with
Direction one which I shall shortly
mention
if any corrections are necessary a
revised version will in due course be
sent to the parties
and published on the Judiciary website
and on the National Archives website
we will give the following directions
for the steps that the parties need to
take consequential on our decision
we direct that by 4 pm on Thursday the
6th of July 2023 1.
the party's file with the court lists of
suggestions for correction of
typographical or other minor errors in
the judgments now handed down
two
the party's file with the court draft
orders in each of the appeals so far as
possible in agreed terms
giving effect to the terms of our
judgments and covering all consequential
matters such as costs and permission to
appeal to the Supreme Court
three
insofar as the terms of the orders
cannot be agreed short written
submissions from the parties on the
disputed items can be filed
in the case of any application for
permission to appeal to the Supreme
Court submissions are required only from
the
applicant submissions from the
respondent will be required only if the
court asks for them
that timetable is deliberately tight
partly so that any application for
permission to appeal to the Supreme
Court can be decided promptly but we
believe it is achievable
any application for an extension will be
entertained only for the most cogent
reasons and should relate only to
particular aspects of the orders in
relation to which it is said that the
timetable cannot be complied with
thank you that concludes this morning's
proceedings
foreign